♪♪
Juliette:
What if what we see is not
what’s out there?
♪♪
(Metal gear locks)
Bernard:
We do not know why we are here.
♪♪
Bernard:
We do not know who built the
silo-
(Crowd cheers)
♪♪
Bernard:
-and why we are underground.
♪♪
Bernard:
We only know-
-the world outside our sanctuary
is death.
♪♪
Holston:
If you boil the pact down to one
rule-
Nernard:
-it’s do not say you want to go
outside,
♪♪
(Soldiers running)
or you will go outside.
♪♪
Don’t you ever think about the
world beyond the silo?
♪♪
What if what we see, is not
what’s out there?
♪♪
Juliette:
Down in mechanical,
♪♪
Juliette:
there’s always someone who has a
theory about the silo,
♪♪
and I need to find out the
truth.
(Lever locks)
♪♪
I found something that might
hold the answers to a lot of
questions.
Holston:
You have to stay quiet.
♪♪
And keep your head down.
(Electrical flash)
(Screams)
♪♪
Are you willing to give
everything you have for this?
♪♪
(Machine hums)
Nernard:
The clock is running.
(Power-down)
There isn't much time left.
(Alarm wails)
♪♪
Holston:
This is a threat to order in the
silo.
Juliette:
I don’t care about order!
What about finding out the
truth?!
♪♪
(Flames ignite)
(Screams)
(Crowd yells)
(Steam blows)
Bernard:
Some mysteries...
♪♪
Bernard:
they're best left
unsolved.
♪♪
(Steel door opens)